here's a fun one john credit card debt
keeps
falling and here's a sad note
banks are on edge dave i've got a
kleenex if you need one i have a tear
banks are on edge the banks americans
are paying down this is uh
this is wall street journal americans
are paying down their credit card debt
at levels not
seen in years that is good news for
everyone
but credit card issuers
large card issuers that cater to
borrowers ranging
from the affluent to the subprime say
the overall card balances and thus the
firm's interest
incomes are falling to make up for it
issuers are spending more on marketing
and they're loosening
their underwriting standards which means
that you don't even have to be alive now
and they will issue you a credit card
they don't have underlying
writing standards they just give
everybody a card
discover set its earnings call last
month that the share of card balances
that were paid off at the end of the
first quarter was the highest level
since the year 2000
capital one what's in your wallet money
said that nearly half of the credit card
balances it had
at the beginning of march were paid off
by the end of the
wow card balances at three companies
including
synchron synchron synchrony i can't even
say that
which is the largest issue of store
credit cards in the u.s
uh the three companies say they're down
nine percent seventeen percent seven
percent the first quarter of the year
perspective
card issuers rely on growing card usage
and balances for their revenue
they're wondering if the pandemic trends
will turn into a long-term
shift we are very focused on returning
to
growing loans i love this next line
delinquencies can't get much lower than
where they are
we can't beat people up anymore
or otherwise keep shrinking your
revenues come down
margins will get worse if if people
don't
keep on screwing up we're gonna make
less money guys
okay guys how how can we and i love
going back to this marketing and
loosening
so here's what's gonna happen you're
gonna start getting these
emails and cards in the mail saying hey
we miss you guys
yep here's some more money you can just
go spend hey dave what happens if
america collectively said whoa
we got our bell rung and we said i don't
want to be the little pig
in the straw house anymore i'm going to
get my crap together i'm going to get
out of debt and have an emergency fund
i'm going to be the little pig in the
brick house so when the
wolf comes and blows i don't have credit
card debt i don't have student loan debt
i don't have car payments i'm under
control and i got a pile of money
you know what would happen discover
would be up a creek
the economy would collapse no it
wouldn't the economy would boom
let me ask you this if you're if you get
completely out of debt
thus you have your entire income to work
with and
you have money saved for emergencies and
saved to buy things
do you then do people then spend
less over the next decade following that
or more i know in my life
we've spent more spend more the house i
bought was more
the because you're affluent yeah you're
building your you have money
you spend and you spend so this idea
that debt
drives the economy is not true now
consumption does drive the economy but
consumption
increases when people aren't broke
so the idea that getting rid of debt in
america and getting rid of this burden
on the back of everyone
is somehow going to cause the american
capitalistic system to completely fail
is asinine because the reality is when
people get out of debt
and have money they spend more money
now they spend it differently right more
intentionally
more wisely but it's not less dollars
being spent on big screens you get nicer
big cities
more dollars being spent on the
equivalent of whatever the consumption
is
because you've got the money yep i mean
think about it if you have to really
think about the big screen and
best buy has to approve you for 90 days
same as cash and you have to go through
a uh you know an entire portfolio of
paperwork just to walk out with your big
screen you shouldn't be buying the
victory well you shouldn't be buying it
but let's say if you have to go that
verse as you go
you know i want one of those uh no i
think i'll take two
and you'll just deliver it to me and
here's the money
now who spends more i mean you know no
really i mean you're not you're not
being crazy
right but the truth is that i make a lot
more money and have a lot more money
than i used to have
and i spend a lot more money than i used
to spend
well no duh you know so this this is the
most wonderful news
in the world and i wish i could take
credit for it but we're not a big enough
deal to take credit for it we're a big
deal
but we're not a big enough deal to shift
the whole economy yet but one of my
goals in life
is to get americans to start treating
the credit card like it's the financial
cigarette
and we are on track baby but uh the the
pandemic came along and helped me with
my goals
because he woke a bunch of you people up
it slapped the silly out of some of you
i think that again my friends make fun
of me for being
overly optimistic all the time but i
think that all by and large people are
good
and i think by and large people um when
backed into a corner
go oh okay and my hope here is
that everyone got their bell rung
nothing can happen to us
we'd forgotten 911 and before that it
had been years
and forgotten in 2008 right and
that everyone realized oh this can go
away overnight but this you know this
can be a segment of america this could
be their
emotional great depression yes they're
never again right
and uh hopefully and that that's really
what this article goes on to say
is happening um and all we're gonna do
around here at ramsey is just throw gas
on that fire baby absolutely
discover cars happening be ready for
them be ready for the credit card
friends struggling oh
no i can't bear it